Writers listen up I've got an offer for you
if you have a story to tell but you feel like your voice isn't being heard
HarperCollins is opening their Author Academy again
starting for next spring
and the applications are now open until the 25th of November
3 courses: one for writing fiction
one for writing non fiction and one for writing children's book
they've only got 15 places on each of these
they're exclusively looking for people from under represented ethnic backgrounds
and you will complete a 6 week course with them
and do loads of master classes and hear from some brilliant authors and get a certificate like I did
I graduated from my course at the beginning of this year
and it was fantastic
because they allow you to submit your manuscript directly to them up to a whole year later
and you get to meet brilliant authors like Sara El-Arifi
who is the author of The Final Strife
across this programme
you get access to 15 hour long master classes about the traditional publishing industry
and you get for 2 hour workshops as well
applications are closing soon and it starts from next January
so get on it!